President Trump is defending the use of
what he calls safe tear gas to stop
migrants trying to rush into the u.s.
u.s. customs and border control
commissioners said more than one
thousand migrants tried to storm the
border on Sunday Mexico's government
said it was about 569 people suspected
of crossing illegally were arrested in
California Mexican officials say 98
others are being deported
the Department of Homeland Security says
more than 600 of the thousands of
migrants are convicted criminals Mireya
Villarreal is on the border in Tijuana
Mexico Maria good morning well good
morning the Trump administration's
strong stance on immigration is not
deterring the migrants here at this
shelter in Mexico in fact just a few
minutes ago about a dozen told us they
admitted they were just at the US border
they tried to sneak in and they were
turned away by Border Patrol agents it's
eerily quiet on the Mexican border along
the Tijuana River Border Patrol agents
are at attention
backed by newly wired fencing to
discourage migrants from crossing over
it's a major contrast to the chaos on
Sunday when agents deployed tear gas and
rubber bullets to turn the Central
American migrants away at a roundtable
in Mississippi last night President
Trump
strongly defended Border Patrol's
response first of all the tear gas is a
very minor form of the tear gas itself
it's very safe the ones that were
suffering to a certain extent were the
people that were putting it out there
now nearly six thousand migrants are
waiting for answers at the Sports
Complex in thea Juana
they are sleeping in tents while Mexican
Federal Police stand nearby ready to use
force if needed the Mexican government
was not ready for a group this size in
just two weeks you can see thousands of
people have grouped in here they
continue to come day by day this is
where they eat sleep shower and even go
to the bathroom cadena Gutierrez is a
mother of three from Honduras she
arrived here with the caravan 16 days
ago and says the shelter's conditions
are terrible are 1 million they have no
water to drink we have no food she said
the bathrooms are overflowing and
contaminated the wanna Secretary of
Social Development Mario Ozuna says the
shelter is over capacity by about two
thousand people we are not prepared to
take in more people he says there isn't
a city in the world who could be
prepared but some have had enough at
this tent run by the International
Organization for Migration about 60 to
100 people a day are lining up to
voluntarily go back to their home
country the Department of Homeland
Security Kirsten Nielsen said in a
statement the violence we saw at the
border was entirely predictable we will
continue to prepare for the next assault
while looking for lasting solutions with
Congress now on the flip side the
Mexican government is now asking the
u.s. to conduct a full investigation of
the non-lethal weapons aimed at Mexican
territory
bianna this is a new Mexican president
takes office this weekend Madea thank
you